my academia is a universe that shows no
signs of slowing down with two
successful movies spin-off mangas video
games and of course the main manga and
anime doing very well it's no surprise
that in 2018 Herick oh she decided to
extend his original plan for the story
his initial goal back in the day was to
end the manga around volume 30 which
would mean the series would have ended
this year if it had stuck to that
luckily that's not happening but the day
will eventually come when Declan the
gang defeats shigaraki and achieve their
goals becoming pros when that happens
as with any cultural phenomenon there
will still be a devoted fanbase out
there myself included and let's just be
honest people there's money to be made
whether it's Hiroko XI who does it or
someone else this universe will not die
once Deku graduates high school today
we're looking at one of my favorite
sequel concepts which is set around 7
years in the future and includes a
revamp to a high school a game-changing
new protagonist with totally different
character motivations to Deku plus new
and original villains and also some
returning villains as well that will
really have a big impact for this
protagonist just before we dive into it
this video is sponsored by crunchyroll
with over 45 million registered users if
you go to crunchyroll.com slash turtle
quark you get a 14-day free trial of
their premium service which includes an
unlimited supply of anime manga and
drama titles every episode is ADD free
and in 1080p HD quality on top of having
all four seasons of my hero is the best
service you can want in terms of getting
into new shows recently I used it to
catch up on black clover and in fact
crunchyroll was the only service in my
country that let me watch up until the
very latest episode I'll be doing more
black cover videos in the future so I
would definitely recommend using
crunchyroll to catch up on the series
additionally because they have an
extensive manga library you can catch up
on one of my favorite manga of all time
attack on titan one amazing stat about
crunchyroll is that they offer more than
90% of all officially licensed anime
content in the world which just blew my
mind so like I said check
crunchyroll.com slash Tyler quirk or
click the link in my description now to
get your 2 week free trial
as we know you a is the most famous and
prestigious Hero School in Japan and
it's produced a bunch of the world's
greatest pros
bearing that in mind horikoshi said the
overall arc introduced an important
character that will be drawn in the
final act of the original series I doubt
he's referring to characters who are
Quercus armless or lifeless but rather
it's everyone's favorite girl Airy
whatever it is the airy will do whatever
reason that makes her so important she's
already fulfilled back agos words of
showing signs of greatness at a young
age she effectively acted as a sidekick
when Deku defeated monster Hall and
before this she performed an insane feat
of power and I know it was kind of by
accident but the point still stands
arey not only has potential to become
great but she actually lives at UA right
now therefore based on everything I just
said she is an excellent choice to be
the first-ever female protagonist of a
series in this universe before we get
into why her story would differ so much
from Dec ooze I want to mention how a
revamped UA could look after all those
years firstly the entrance exam would be
modified to play to the strengths of all
different types of heroes this means
that students who have non battle
oriented quirks like shinzo or Kazuma
they would all have a chance to shine
rather than destroying robots students
would take place in fake villain attacks
which is quite similar to the
provisional license exam and during this
exam that would be graded equally based
on how well they help people how good
they are at stopping villains and you
know how how well they work with their
fellow examinees as Aizawa said the
current system just isn't rational
because it rewards people with flashy
attack type quirks a bit too much this
new exam which weighs all these
different things equally it would pave
the way for all different types of
heroes to get into you as hero course
however much like so Totoro key I have
no doubt that an Ares case she would get
into you a via a special recommendation
if we're being logical I mean she's been
training her quark since the age of 6
with Professor Sawa and her ties to the
school I mean they would be deeper than
anyone else applying because you know
she's lived there so it's rational that
she would go and do this special
recommendation exam instead if not just
given a straight pass to join without
doing any
I'm sorry but if I lived at a school for
the majority of my childhood I would
actually be personally offended if you
didn't like just let me in the second
change is that us here of course would
introduce a ranking system that will
motivate students and create a positive
rivalry as a comparison one of my
favorite shows as a child was yu-gi-oh
GX and in that show people wanting to
become pro duelists had to attend Duel
Academy and they were ranked into three
separate groups based on their
performance in the entrance exam the
best of the best were put into obelisk
blue the mid-level students were put
into raw yellow and then the lower
ranked ones were put into Slifer red
they could then be Arirang based on
their results at school this system
works because it provides a greater
incentive for students in the lower
ranks to consistently go plus ultra and
prove themselves Cyrus was the best
example of this as he began this series
as a Slifer and moved up each year
eventually graduating as an obelisk blue
having a group system also puts pressure
on the top students to consistently
perform as sliding down the ranks is not
a good look in the sequel series that I
imagine at least the best hero
candidates in the entrance exam would be
put into a group in the same vein as
obelisk blue only in this show the group
would be named after all my students in
this bracket have the privilege of
wearing the blue you a gym uniform as
this color scheme represents all my it's
golden age and it's also the same
uniform that students at UA have worn
for decades so it has a lot of history
following that it's only right that the
second-best group would be named after
endeavour and would wear red gym
uniforms this represents both his fire
and his fiery personality both
characters could potentially be dead by
the time this whole sequel happens so it
would be nice to pay homage to both of
them and behind this group would be a
neutral group which isn't named after
any hero in particular remember that
endeavour and all might are pretty
unique and they're basically freaks of
nature no other Japanese here that we
know of compares to either of them for
that reason this group would wear a very
neutral white color which would be worn
by every single other student in the
school so that means general studies
where this the business course where
this and obviously the lower ranked hero
students wear this this would make
things like the sports for
Stables so much more epic i mean imagine
how much more exciting it is to have a
kid in all my blue up against someone in
endeavor red who clearly has a point to
prove or even better you can have
someone in the white trying to show that
just as capable as the upper ranks but
like I said every student on the hero
course has the chance to be moved up
into a higher group and be re ranked if
they improve so now that we've
established what a revamp ta might look
like let's get into who Aires friends
and rivals might be as well as the
evolving villains that she'll have to
deal with cat Zuma and Kota are two
young children that have already shown
off the potential in the original series
and in the Maya academia movie starting
with Kota he might not have that raw
natural strength but when it comes down
to it he did show bravery in distracting
muscular and saving Dec whose life in
the process meanwhile cat Sumer was so
brave that he charged directly at a guy
with nine quirks and attacked him which
is just insane considering the damage he
had done throughout that whole movie to
run up an attack in like that you gotta
have a fearless streak inside you both
of these guys would no doubt get into
you way especially with deku probably
helping them out
I reckon Kota would be put into the
neutral group as his power is unrefined
but he has the heart of a true hero and
obviously massive room to improve in
consumers case he's one that I can see
starting in the endeavor red group and
moving up to the all my group down the
road his quirk is so good that an entire
movie was dedicated to stealing it but
on the other side it's not very flashy
and when coupled with his soft-spoken
nature it makes him very easy to
overlook both of them are strongly
linked with Deku and it's likely that
this connection will bring them together
as friends with area included on the
other hand I think a very obvious choice
for Ares rival would be tamashiro in
season four we were introduced to these
students of masa gawky primary school
who were all noted as being very
overpowered for their age in the manga
he eggs on all of his classmates to
fight the UA students with his binging
book work being so fast but even back
ago could not avoid it he'd make a great
fit for the all my blue group as he
clearly has immense talent and
confidence but I think he would be an
unlikely ally and rival of Airy
so basically fulfilling the backer girl
role of the series now moving on in
terms of the villains that he could face
I have two selections for this video
that I think you guys will really agree
with the first idea has never been done
before in my hero and that is to have a
totally original villain with no quirk
every villain we've seen right they
either have multiple quirks overpowered
quirks or insane skill but what if there
was someone who literally just used
their brain what if we had a bad guy who
was truly like the evil version of Deku
I mean I know they imply that gentle
criminal was sort of like what Deku
might have turned out to be but no I'm
talking about someone who genuinely does
not have a quirk who was bullied in the
same way that Deku was and became more
resentful and hateful over the years
rather than getting lucky in the same
way that Deku did by you know being
given a quote by the greatest hero this
person on the other hand never got that
lucky break they just grew up
hateful and envious of quirk Society
someone who's just causing havoc with
their mind and trying to erase all
quirks but because they want equality
well I think that would be pretty cool
to be honest and following that the
second idea I had for a villain will
probably not surprise you given who the
protagonist is of this sequel series but
overall would make a surprise comeback
during this series as I think it would
have very personal ramifications for
Arry and potentially throw her off her
game a bit facing her abuser as an adult
having now lived most of her life
without him that would be a dynamic that
we've never seen in this universe and it
could allow for some very dramatic
character development she'd likely have
to explain her past to her friends and
open up about why she's so afraid of
this guy and perhaps her knowledge of
him will ultimately be what allows the
heroes to win seeing overall comeback
would be an awesome throwback for fans
of the original show as no one can deny
that this guy single-handedly pushed the
limits of how dark my hero academia can
be perhaps when he makes his comeback he
could have like an evolved version of
his quirk whereas obviously you know he
lost his hands because of Shigure aki so
now he just uses his feet and he just
walks around bare for everywhere
destroying things how exactly would a
first season of this series play out
like I said he would get into you way by
a special recommendation which would be
a nice calm contrast to the hell that
Deku went through before he took the
edge
exam instead of a story of a boy with
with no hope of becoming a hero
it's instead a story of a girl who's
confused about the type of hero that she
wants to be the sequel series could
begin with an explanation of the current
state of your society and you know how
you way has changed and of course the
dominance of the new top to pro heroes
they'd be in their 20s and yeah it's
more than realistic that they'd be the
top two given that Hawkes was in the top
three when he was like 18 endeavour was
top you know he was the second best hero
when he was 20 so yeah by this point I
reckon back ago and deccan could well be
the top two heroes after this has been
explained if you remember in the
original series
I saw word deprived class 1a of the
chance to attend the entrance ceremony
or any guidance sessions for that matter
um so those are things that we never
actually got the chance to see because
of Ares ties to Aizawa she would likely
be put into class 1b to avoid any
potential favoritism from from Aizawa
and that means that she'd get to attend
this ceremony and do the things that we
never got to see class when I doing my
thought process is that for a ceremony
like that you would it wouldn't be too
weird if a successful former student
made an appearance and gave a speech to
inspire everyone if that was to happen
then I have no doubt it would of course
be the living goat that is adult deku
who by this point has mastered one for
all defeated shigaraki and probably done
a bunch of crazy other stuff that I
haven't even thought about Zuko could
give an anecdote about his first day at
UA and how he was almost expelled if it
wasn't for a quick bit of creative
thinking that would be a nice throwback
for us who watched the original series
and I think for new viewers as well it
would be a pretty funny moment now
thinking about the students themselves
you know airy and kazuma
I think it would make them believe that
anything is possible knowing that
someone as strong and you know as high
ranking as deku used to be someone who
was so close to being expelled on day
one after this it would be a perfect
opportunity for Aryan consumer to make
friends as they'd likely both be
fanboying pretty hard in the same way
that Bakugan and Deku just found boy
your overall might I imagine this would
be a similar dynamic every would get put
into the top group of students alongside
tamashiro and it's likely that their
personalities would clash right from the
beginning
some reason I feel like tamashiro is way
more of a back ago Stan the rest of the
season wood Prairie in pretty
interesting situations typically you'd
have you know cost battles sports
festival rivalries and of course a work
study with Minetta hey he did say he was
looking forward to meeting her again as
endeavor said when a hero sets up an
agency they focus on evacuation rescue
or battle and I think Aries collective
experiences in the first season would
help her realize what type of hero she
wants to be in fact now that I'm just
thinking about it off the top I'm
thinking that maybe overall breaking out
of jail could be like the cliffhanger
for the first season I think that would
just blow everyone's minds but let me
know down below do you think it's a good
idea for overhaul to return or do you
think we should just stick to a
completely new original villains Kota
would not appear in the first season of
this because when I checked the numbers
he's actually one full year younger than
Airy and for that reason he wouldn't
appear until her second year at UA when
I checked a mashiro's age he actually
has no confirmed age so as far I mean
you can just make him whatever age you
want really
so if horikoshi was to do this he could
just say tamashiro is the same age as
air he wouldn't make too much of a
difference also cut Sumer is in the same
academic year as Airy so that's all good
they both be the same age when they
start you way so yeah they definitely
get to know each other especially being
massive deku fans and yeah that was
pretty much my idea for now I mean let
me know what you think is this hole just
overall is it something you'd like to
see or do you think if we were to
continue might hear academia - do you
think we should just follow the
characters that we already know as pro
heroes let me know down below and thank
you guys so much for watching peace out
guys